Come on. Wait, it's in the same glass as well.
It's contaminated with the that you bought wine. And Chris made me do.
This disgusting abomination.
This is the Carlsberg of shocking, like I bet this is.
If you don't know, Carlsberg is a godawful beer. Um, they're awful. Have you,
have you noticed that in Japan sometimes they'll have Carlsburg are calling and
they'll be like foreign beer.
And I'm like, no, no, no, no, no. I know that's not water. Basically.
They'll be like, it's called Miller light. It's an exquisite foreign beer,
you know? And you're like, no, no, no, I don't what this is.
It's just the good stuff. Let's talk offish this the good stuff again,
right? Like again, like, as we were saying,
Connor's not a soccer drinker in the same way that he's,
I'm not a whiskey drinker. Right. You've got wine now.
So I use white wine from Yamanashi when I first came.
Japan, I desperately wanted to be that guy who was like, I love everything.
Japan. I'm called a sewer of Japan.
You've assessed with soccer, press X to doubt. He was never like that, man.
That was like, I can't believe you just looked at my life
when I wasn't with you.
Yes. What drink do you want to be? Like suck it. Of course.
Where were you? Every time he wasn't with us. Yeah, of course.
Because I knew that you would call me out on that.
If I go to a bar and I'm like, he's just like middle of light, please.
Don't actually like with you guys, I'm like be a policeman, but like,
cause I don't want to be called out. Like, cause if I'm with him.
Everyone, right.
And everyone orders beer and one person who's on their first vacation to Japan
goes of a soccer. Actually I'd be like.
Off, off. You're you're just getting too into the Japan atmosphere,
but it tastes like.
There's a reason why a bottle of psyche never costs more than $20.
The thing I've noticed very quickly about soccer that I noticed about just
regular wine is that I hate soccer normally.
But if I have it with a good meal and like a meal that fits the Sockeye,
I disagree, then I love it. We've got no meal though. Yeah.
It took me a little longer than usual.
What got me to like wine was having my first red wine with a nice, to be honest.
Wine goes fantastically with meals. I agree. It's not.
Nope. It's Nope. It's not wine. Isn't it.
Too strong. Well like it's overpowering. Saki is like, when you,
when you have your steak, whatever, and you have a soccer, it's like, great.
Now I'm just drink soccer with this steak.
What do you eat it with? It's usually fish.
You have fish, right? Yeah. Whatever the. I don't give a.
There's a reason why they serve a lot of soccer. Like sushi, rice. Yeah.
But when you have it, you have this fishing debate. You have the debate.
Chris, help me out here.
Cause this is what happens when we've talked about food on the podcast,
that guy, we always have those heated debates about food. Like whenever,
whenever food's brought us up, we turned into a bunch of apes. I swear to God.
I like when people drink.
Like hard liquor with a meal or something, I'm like, you have,
you are immediately just like absolutely bombing your mouth.
It's a wine. It's like 20%, 20% is wine.
What are your opinions? As the adjudicator of this argument help me.
Red wine is 15 to 20%. Saki is 15, 20% Lima, 20% wine Gerry.
You think I'm a wine Somalia. There is no wine.
That is 20%. That is. I've never seen that.
I have seen that. That's probably a wine that again. Wow,
come on. But no, I like, I much prefer wine over Saki.
Um, I feel like.
12 To 15% is the perfect zone.
And anything above that starts to get like tastes like vodka, right. And
18%. But that still tastes like a hard alcohol, right?
This is you lie. It doesn't lie. Why did that burn for you? Yes.
18%. 18% Christian. That's not Vocus 37.5. But the thing.
Is I can't distinguish the difference between that. Yeah.
And vodka. That is why you fail. What do you want? No, no, no, no, no.
What's wrong here.
I'm not partly on your side until you have the audacity to save that for
someone who loves food so much,
you can tell the difference between vodka and wine.
What I think is it that is strong enough where it's in the same category as a
vodka tasting.
No God makes you want to die more a hundred percent.
But Sakhi does still have the same kind of.
I only have like, I drink it and I'm like, ah, immediately, um,
where's the wine. I'm like, I drink it. And I'm like.
Ooh, I can't believe what I'm hearing. You're Japanese.
Don't eat some whale.
Oh, that chicken and broccoli is.
You're taken seriously sucky on the same level as Bucky.
Disgusting. Listen, they both taste like mine. I mean,
I'm not going to down wrong.
I love how we've gotten two hours into this. And we actually,
we just drank a ton of Saki unwillingly. And now it's a mess or a podcast.
Thank you, Chris. I think if you watch this episode with a bit of, bit of sock,
it's chicken broccoli. Oh,
D experience here. Now, now that we're on the topic of alcohol.
Fine. Okay. Your least favorite alcohol. Is it all on the same level?
Because anything above 20% is the same to you then? Honestly.
Like in like vodka, tequila, whiskey. Okay.
[Inaudible] this man contradicts himself. I want, I want to be like Phoenix.
Right? Right now. Bring like
a contradiction in your statement.
Gin. Gin actually tastes nice.
I'm not saying that. No,
I'm not saying that because I'm British and that that's that's our cultural
expo. Are we talking like just gin on its own or like a gin and tonic? Tonic.
Okay. Gin and tonic is on a different level. Gin and tonic.
Person who drinks, drinks. Gin. gin straight. No, no one. Exactly.
Because you don't hear it. Like when you.
Vodka and Coke, what do you think? I think depressing university days.
Like I'm desperate to get drunk. Yeah. Right Chris. Yeah, exactly.
What is the last time you had a vodka and Coke? Chris?
I vote ketonic every week.
Whiskey.
You have straight. Right? And never like, okay. Whiskey and Coke.
Sounds like it.
Great whiskey and Cokes. All right. But I mean like I, I rarely drink whiskey.
Whiskey is more of a mood setter. Whiskey is there for like you don't,
you don't want to get drunk on whiskey. No, no. I like, I,
if people would get drunk on whiskey are drinking whiskey way too fast for me.
It's like, you can't have a drink that you just kind of like it,
it warms you up. But either way I don't care for it. Right.
It's like a nightcap. Basically.
We all know the superior drink is an espresso martini.
Right? No,
that's true because your body is just addicted to caffeine drinks like
Chris, my coffee, eight cups of coffee every day. Wind down here.
Go on.
It's tainted with second cup.
Now put it in the same disgusting cup for the people.
It'd be a terrible Somalia.
No,
a terrible Somalian. Somalia. You'll be a terrible Somalia.
Somalia, Somalia. Isn't it? Is it? Isn't it Somalia? I dunno.
I can't smell. I don't know someone.
Someone French canal would not be a terrible Somalian,
but I get that there right now. Jordan, how is it pronounced?
[inaudible] that's closer to my pronunciation. Malian, Somalia,
Somalians watching this a fraud thing right now. Oh my God. Come on. They,
they notice those.
Resident Frenchman who sounded closer to my pronunciation than yours.
What do you want? I will fight this battle to the death.
I am known for being stubborn and I won't quit.